لا احد يستغني عن العطر يشتريها الناس
اكثر من اي وقت مضى وفق تقرير جديد يزدهر
حجم سوق العطور في جميع انحاء العالم
ويتوقع ان تصل قيمه سوق العطور الى اكثر
من 50 مليار دولار بحلول عام 2029 يعني
بمعدل نمو سنوي يبلغ
3.4% ليش هذا الازدهار لماذا هذا الازدهار
ربما لاننا الناس اكتشفت بعد العزل ايام
كورونا اهميه العطر في التواصل بين البشر
فالعطر لا يقتصر على رائحه لطيفه وفقه
طبعا الدراسه بل يمكن ان يكون امتدادا
لشخصيتك بالفعل يقال عادل بانه حاسه الشم
هي واحده من اقوى الحواس لدى الانسان يمكن
للعطر المناسب ان يعطي
عنك دون حديث بالاضافه الى انه يجعل الناس
لا ينسونك في اي وقت قريب مع دخول فصل
الصيف وارتفاع درجات الحراره
اختيار العطر المناسب يعد امر في غايه
الاهميه فكيف نختار هذا العطر تكفون ركزوا
على هذه النقطه
عندي مشكله بعد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اللي مدى بعيد لان العطر يعكس شخصيه الرجل
في حاله كانت فخامه او شيء زي كذا فلابد
منه ان العطر يظهر نوعيه الرجل شخصيته
من من شخصيه الشخص لانه بالنهايه كل واحد
بده يفتش على وسيله
فرجه صورته للمجتمع يعني على حسب الموقف
لانه اذا شميت العطر تذكر موقف جدا ضروري
انه كل شخص يكون عنده ريحه وكل شخص تدل
يعني على شخصيتها من ريحته الصراحه
سبعين بالميه
من شخصيته
[موسيقى]
اي والله الان راح اقول لكم لانه بعض
الناس للاسف يختارون العطور ثقيله في فصل
الصيف وخاصه احنا في شهر وشهر سبعه والحر
وهذا تقلب كارثه عموما اختيار العطر هو
شخصيتك كيف تختار هذا العطر هنا في
الاستوديو معنا خبير العطور بشار حكيم راح
يحدثنا بشار صباح الخير انا انسان طبيعي
ولا لا لانه انا اخلط ما بين
الاورينتل على السويت على احب الخلطه هذه
اربعه او خمسهم فوق بعض
هذا من اعتبره خلط لا بالعكس احنا نعتبره
شغف ايوه لان احنا بالشرق الاوسط نعشق
العطر نحب العطور وهذا يجي من تاريخنا
واحنا هذا يعتبرز مالتنا من احنا صغار
ولدنا وحوالينا في العطور فاكيد ريحه
البخور وين بنروح دهن العود فهذا يعتبر من
الشغف مالتنا فلا هذا انت تخربط بس تحتاج
شلون نقول مثلا عندك الخزانه وتحتاج ترتيب
الها لانه مش كل العطور بتمشي مع بعضها
يعني مش كل النوتس وبالانجليزي يقال يعني
لدرجه العطر هاي كلها بتمشي مع بعضها طيب
كيف ممكن نختار العطر المناسب خصوصا في
فصل الصيف شو مقومات العطور الصيفيه خلينا
نقول الصراحه غلط ولا في شيء صح احنا
بالنسبه اذا نريد نتكلم على العطور اذا
نريد نختار عطر النا نسميه اتيكيت العطور
كيف احنا نكون عندنا الاختيار العطر
يكون عدنا نعرف متى نستخدم العطر
والمناسبه اللي احنا فيها يعني مثلا نروح
نزور شخص في المستشفى لازم نعرف شو العطر
المخلي مثلا نخلي شي ماسكي كلين ريحه
نظافه اذا مثلا درجه حراره الصيف كثير
عاليه هنا الامارات
والجو حار كثير ورطوبه بس اذا اريد نخلي
عطر مثلا عندنا مناسبه احنا قاعدين في
فندق او في صاله وفيها تبريد سوري مثلا
عطر يكون مميز ولازم نعرف شنو احنا نريد
نوصل بهذا العطر هل هذا العطر احنا نريد
فقط ان نريد نستمتع به هل هذا العطر اريد
اخليه يكون كتوقير او العطر هذا مثلا يكون
كي اكسبوجر عشان الناس كلها عشان تلفت
بالضبط
الاتجاه معين بالعطر
نطبق انطبق يعني كيف بتلبس العطر او بترشه
على نفسك برضه اله طقوس
بطريقه مختلفه بالشرق الاوسط ما شاء الله
اختصاص اكثر تفضل شلون شلون بس حتى لان
انا اخاف يدركنا الوقت
شلون نعرف انه هذا العطر من الممكن انه
هذا يعكس شخصيتي وبالتالي انا اعطي هذا
الاستيتمنت او الموقف اللي تجي على اختصاص
شخص مختص بهذا الشيء سو مثلا اذا تجي علي
ونلتقي في يوم من الايام احطه اعرف احنا
باقي لنا دقيقه يلا اوكي لازم اي واحد راح
نجرب مثلا لازم اعرف مثلا شخصيتك ومن تر
العطر متمرد بانه يكون على هالطريقه احنا
بالنسبه لنا اني هاي طريقتي العطر لازم
تشم العطر بهالطريقه على مود تشم العطر
قلب العطر دائما تحب
شغفها زين الان اوكي انا جربته نعم بهذا
نعم بجرب واحد ثاني احنا لازم شو نسوي
بعدين اذا حبيت العطر هذه الطريقه اللي
وصلت لك اياها الفكره بعدين نخليه على
جسمك لان على الجسم يختلف صح اكيد احنا
عندنا مثلا نقول انت اللي تعطر العطر مش
العطر اللي هو يعطرك يخلط مع السبايسيز
اللي موجوده مع حتى يكون شيء معين ويكون
مختلف من شخص الى اخر طيب ايضا بدات ان
اسال انه في معروف بانه بالعطور في ثلاثه
نوت او ثلاث مستويات التوب نوت اللي هي
اول ما نرش العطر من شمها واخر وحده هي
اللي بتضلها لبعدين
يعني بعد قديه منرش العطر نقدر نقول انه
هاي هي الريحه الحقيقيه لاله
اوكي بكل عطر يكون اشي مختلف ودائما تكون
هي الريحه اللي تكون خفيفه هي اللي حتكمل
تستمر بالعطر والاخيره اللي هي اللي راح
تبقى وتشميها اكثر راح تبقى على الجسم
العطر اذا تريديه يستمر اكثر اوكي لازم
تخليه على مناطق النبض اذا تخليه على
القماش اوكي العطر راح يكون فواح بس سوري
مستمر بس اذا تريدين يكون فواح اكثر يكون
على الجسم سوكو فرق بين الاستمراريه
والفواحه وحبيت على مواد اماكن النبض يعني
على الرقبه على اليد مثلا خليني اقول لكم
انا ترى قبل شوي شمينا بهذه الطريقه ما
كانت حلوه او ريحه العطر ما كانت هي بس
بطريقه بشار اختلفت
العفو اهلا وسهلا بشار الحكيم يعطيك
العافيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات